[Music]
we just reviewed the RTX 4070 TI super
and now we're reviewing the 7600 XT
bonus I get to go home and sleep after
this we spend like two days anyway we're
going to be reviewing the 7600 XD has
doubled the memory of the original 7600
it is
$330 that's a big price jump considering
the price class the 7600 was already in
which was 270 bucks so going up to 330
pretty big change uh and then that's
pending obviously the partner models and
seeing what they land at but we're on a
tear right now with kind of iterating
and gradually adding to our GPU test
Suite so we just added cyberpunk RT for
the 407 TI super review you can see the
methodology there on the discussion
about it that's in here too and then we
also just added balers Gate 3 back in
for another 2023 title that is
particularly relevant at this class of
card something like a 470 TI super it
didn't really matter you're going to be
CPU Bound in most cases anyway or just
at silly frame rate for balers gate but
for this one it's particularly relevant
we also added power efficiency testing
yesterday and we're using that for the
76 XT as well that is actually important
for this card because in addition to the
memory change the only other meaningful
change is that the power budget has
increased which means higher power
consumption we'll see on the efficiency
impact but that's going to encourage
higher clocks so there should be
differences even in scenarios where the
memory is going to be irrelevant because
maybe not leveraging it but otherwise
the CU counts the same the stream
processor count is the same the memory
interface is the same same so it's
capacity and power budget airgo
frequency that are changing before that
this video is brought to you by
Squarespace and visiting squarespace.com
Gamers Nexus will give you 10% off your
first purchase with them we've built a
number of our own websites with
Squarespace where we list catastrophic
PC Hardware failures to inform
subscribers of those failures we also
built our store website with Squarespace
using its built-in e-commerce tools and
of course we built a website for our CEO
snowflake because she demanded our
audience know who really run the show
get to the core of your idea and spend
less time on web design by signing up at
squarespace.com Gamers Nexis or click
the link below let's start with setting
the stage for a quick pricing update if
you haven't checked lately Jeremy on the
team put together this quick reference
table for you all for gpus that might be
relevant in this price range we averaged
the price of several of the cheapest
cards for each skew uh one of these only
had one available because it's basically
gone but we eliminated outliers that
were high priced like those by third
party sellers dark 7600 is currently
averaging about 274 bucks so it's still
near the launch price the RX 7700 XT the
prior next class up is $454 now and the
7600 XE will be determined at launch you
should maybe see those prices today but
it should be about 330 where you can
still find the 60600 it's about $213
which definitely keeps it relevant the
a750 is also super relevant and is as
low as $190 now but typically around 200
to 210 or so the 6650 XT is also Rel
event at
$260 as is the 6700 XT which is a direct
price alternative to the 7600 XT and it
runs 12 GB of memory that's more likely
to be utilized than the 16 on the 7600
XT nvidia's closest competition Remains
the RTX 4060 it hasn't launched anything
near the a750 price class yet for this
generation as always other options might
include the used Market but for AMD
looking at new cards its fiercest
competition is really going be itself
from prior Generations it's still
contending with whatever remains of the
6000 series inventory definitely should
be dwindling by now but it's still out
there and otherwise the a750 is worth
paying attention to but remember that
that one is still kind of variable we
posted a video maybe about a month ago
doing a one-year revisit of Intel Arc
where we spent the entire video talking
about the drivers so uh if you haven't
been updated lately that's worth check
it out because they have improved a lot
but they still have some issues all
right so respects this is again
functionally identical other than those
two characteristics the power and the
memory capacity so don't expect massive
sways and those that you see will be
from one of those two characteristics uh
and we'll look into the power
consumption a little bit later in this
review so let's get straight into the
testing we'll just run the power
efficiency stuff first this is brand new
for us we explained this in the 4070 TI
super review in depth and had a lot more
charts but we'll just be showing One
initial chart here for today for the
7600 XD partly for time reasons but but
also partly because the one Starfield
chart really does tell most of the story
for the 7600 XT for efficiency and again
this is all brand new testing for us so
we will be changing and iterating on
this as a reminder this is an FPS per
watt or effectively frames per Jewel
higher is better and the RX 7600 XT is
the worst on this chart down at 0.27 FPS
per watt that has it behind the original
7600 which was more efficient in this
test by 12% interestingly there was
about a 12% change at most in Starfield
between these cards so it's scaled at
least fairly close to one to one for
performance increase in this particular
game but that still makes it clear where
AMD got its gains which is blasting more
power with the car now 40 Watts higher
in total power consumption the 10-point
highs won't be charted separately this
time but for those we landed at 229 wats
for the 76 XT and 196 for the 7600 and
if you watch nothing else from the 47 TI
super review check out the efficiency
section for more information on this new
testing uh we also have the 4060 we'll
be adding to the charts in the next run
the first summary charts look at the RX
7600 XT versus the RX 7600 remember the
power budget drives part of this with
the memory driving the larger numbers
but only in scenarios where the memory
is actually utilized cyberpunk with
raate tracing has recently added to our
testing with medium settings we saw
about an 11% increase at 1080p with rt
whereas we saw a significant increase of
34% with 1440p now 1440p that's not a
playable frame rate so in that respect
it does doesn't matter but percentage
wise it serves its academic purpose
which is illustrating that the memory
can have an impact when constrained it's
just that the card at a core level isn't
fast enough for the memory to be
relevant here despite the Improvement
it's still unplayable onto the rest of
the games generally speaking we're
seeing about 52% uplift at 4K were
tested and about 7% uplift at 1440p and
1080p some breakouts include F1 at 10%
for 4K and Starfield at 12% for 1080p RT
uplift was generally within the same
range aside from cyberp Punk's more
intensive settings if we eliminate
cyberp punk from the averaging that
brings the approximate Improvement down
closer to 5% from 7% and that's in
exchange for 22% more money so not great
and the scenarios where you need that
memory while also still being in
playable territory are going to be rare
the de summary has to be broken into two
pieces we're presenting RT separately
from rzed testing as we explained in the
4070 TI super review we do this because
we try to keep as much of the math as as
possible in the direction of percent
increase anyway here are the RT results
when moving from the RX 7600 XT to the
RTX 460 the scale is insane for cyberp
Punk with the newly added testing we
accommodate both cyber Punk with ultra
RT and with medium RT and we did that
because we noticed increase in RT load
on the GPU disproportionately favors
Nvidia which is a real Advantage so we
represent it but we wanted to represent
both options fairly at 1080p with rt
Ultra we saw an 85% uplift the 7600 XT
compared to the 4060 here is crumbling
under this much load the 1440p result
really isn't fully representative of the
differences because the cards are both
so overloaded that they are totally
unplayable without any upscaling
assistance and even then it'd be rough
so uh the nature of being overloaded is
that the FPS numbers start skewing uh
even still though at 60% with the lower
and reduced medium RT settings the RTX
460 maintains an advantage of about 30%
still significant in ding Light 2 the
RTX 460 has about a 26 to 33% advantage
after that we have three lighter RT
workloads that fall below 15%
Improvement for the RTX 460 this gives
you a fairly representative picture of
the two types of RT titles right now
those that supplement raster graphics
and those that frontload RT visuals it's
up to you on what kind of games you play
with regard to whether this matters with
rasterized benchmarks only and now
looking at the percentage Improvement in
the 7600 XT against the 460 with the
7600 XT going in the positive direction
we see an average wash between them when
it's better the 7600 XT tends to be
about 3 to 5% better over on the right
when it's worse it tends to be about 2%
to 5% worse generally speaking it most
consistently did worse in 4k with games
that are lighter Tomb Raider GTA and
Final Fantasy won't meaningfully utilize
that extra vram if at all so it provides
no value as such and particularly in
Final Fantasy where we tend to see
Nvidia disproportionately favored
counter to Starfield which
disproportionately favors AMD it's the
core facts of the GPU that matter more
more than the vram in the 2023 remake of
Resident Evil 4 the RX 7600 XT ran at
72.7 FPS average against the 69.9 FPS of
the
7600 normally we'd round those two
numbers but we need every fraction of a
frame of difference to even begin to
tell these two cards apart unless memory
bound the 7600 xt's lead is 4% it's
actually lower than what we were seen
with the 4070 TI super at 1080p levels
of uplift territory when compared to the
470 TI yesterday the 7600 xt's closest
Nvidia competition would be the RTX 460
at 68.8 FPS average that's just below
the 7600 and there's no meaningful
difference to frame pacing it's between
the two for Price here the RTX 460 TI 8
GB card is about $390 to $400 so it's
20% more expensive than MSRP for the
7600 XT and about 24% more performance
in average FPS up at 90 as for the 6600
XT comparison from last generation it
doesn't really meaningfully move the
needle it's not perfectly linear either
but there's not a big change here at
1080p the RX 7600 xt's 110 FPS average
led the 7600 by a staggering mindblowing
4.1% we were worried we'd have to break
out the double digits for this review
but fortunately it looks like we might
not have to because as we all know
numbers above 10 are in finite Supply we
just wastefully used one right there
saying the number 10 that was another
one rumor has it that this is also why
Nvidia launched its 4070 TI super to
protect the supply of double digigit
numbers as for competition the 4060 ends
up right between them when compared to
the newest test run they're about the
same including in 1% lows the 460 TI 8
GB runs about 28% ahead of the 76 XT at
20% price bump here intels a750 is due
another round of testing with its
current beta drivers but as of 10 days
ago with the release drivers a750 was
clocked at 105 FPS average in this test
that has it just below the 7600 Baseline
cart Intel currently has a 70 to $80
price advantage over the 7600 so this is
fiercely competitive here it's still
more sporadic than Nvidia and AMD for
game to game reliability but it has
significantly improved from launch
actually we have a one year later
revisit video if you want to learn more
about how Intel has updated its drivers
Starfield is up next tested at 1440p
this 2023 title has the 7600 XT at 51.7
FPS average and the 7600 non XT at 46.6
FPS average it's about an 11% swing to
the XT Which is far more than we saw in
many of the other games tested today
it's actually the most exciting it'll
get F1 is also in this range later on
this result positions the 7600 as behind
the 4060 which itself is behind the 360
TI and then the 7600 XT is behind the
4060 TI the 4 60 TI leads it by about
15% here at 1080p the RX 7600 XT leads
by 12% over the original 7600 this is
significant in comparison to other
positions we've seen in this testing
unfortunately that doesn't show up in
many other places uh and the 7600 XT
ends up about equal to a 6700 XT here
with the 7600 behind the 4060 on the
Ballers Gate 3 we started running
entirely new tasks for this since it's
been updated so much since our last
round but the last couple hours before
posting this while running the new cards
we got six cards through and we noticed
that overall the results aren't too
different since September we're still
rerunning everything building new charts
but for purposes of giving you as much
referential data as possible while we
still build this out we are including
the old data too anything marked 124 is
directly comparable some quick examples
4K here the 7700 XT has improved 3.8%
from the September version of the game
with the 4060 not too different from its
original result for directly comparable
data at 4K the 7600 XT is about 5%
better than the 7600 as freshly tested
and roughly equal to the 4060 the 4060
TI is 47 FPS average result gives it a
strong lead over the new XT as well
1440p is up now old to new because
that's more interesting than the 7600 XT
apparently we saw a 3 and a half% uplift
in the 7600 since September 4% in the
4060 since September and 3.2% for the
3060 we also saw 7.6% for the 7700 XT
it's interesting data to have as well
but for direct comparisons with our new
data the 7600 XT leads the 7600 by the
same predictable amount we've seen a few
times now with the 4060 sitting about
tied with it once again d light 2 from
2022 is up next in this one the 7600 XT
ran at 58.9 FPS average again we'll need
every one of those digits that's as
compared to the 7600
56.7 a staggering
3.88% difference if AMD had pulled in
Nvidia and done a price for- price swap
we'd be more neutral towards that change
but a price hike for under 4% is simply
not worth it in this scenario the a750
manages to outperform the 7600 and it's
just behind the 7600 XT including with
roughly equivalent lows it's great
positioning for Intel's GPU and shows
driver maturity as well nvidia's 4060 is
between the 7600 and 7600 XT as well
with in distinguishably different lows
the 4060 TI leads the 7600 XT by 177%
here so its Advantage has diminished in
this game at 1080p the RX 7600 to 86 FPS
average allows the new 7600 XT El lead
of 6 and half% that's so exciting we
can't wait to pay 22% more money for
that and video's 460 sits between these
two again so this is perhaps one of the
limp games of Leap Frog since the launch
of Skylake number 39 the a770 is also
between the 7600 XT and the 7600 with
the a750 behind a bit 4060 TI again sets
the ceiling for this group of cards none
of the cards on the chart would be worth
upgrading from one of these you'd have
to go further back like maybe to a 1050
TI and at that point anything's a huge
upgrade so having a percent difference
doesn't matter you might as well just go
by the relative between your modern
options now we're moving to our older
and reliable set of benchmarks which
allows us to have years of comparative
data against older cards these are
mostly useful for rapidly establishing
scaling performance although we're
adding new games we won't necessarily be
replacing all of the old Suite along
with the new ones we might run them
partly in tandem to give us more percent
scaly numbers to work with it's also
useful for seen scaling at things like
4K with a more medium workload speaking
of here it is at 4K the 7600 XT ran at
51 FPS average behind the 460s 54 FPS
result and ahead of the 7600 49 FPS
average result wait sorry 48.8 it's a
3.5% Advantage so great maybe AMD can
sponsor another F1 team with all the
extra money per XT they sell Intel's
a750 runs at 49 FPS average here with
lows actually in step with the average
that has it between the 7600 and 7600 XT
while costing significantly less if
you're willing to deal with the
occasional Intel Arc driver issues some
of which are not resolvable by the user
at 1440p the 7600 XTS 102 FPS average
Has It 2 and a half% ahead of the 7600
tied with the RTX 460 and meaningfully
ahead of the a750 this time this isn't
interesting so let's move on in F1 at 4K
the RX 76 00 XT ran at 62 FPS average
leading the 4060 by 8.6% and the 7600 by
10.3% that's at least a meaningful
change it's not worth the money for it
but it's one of those sparingly used
double digigit numbers and we haven't
seen many of those this time this seems
to align with the resolution bump which
is likewise reflected in the lows of the
7600 versus the 7600 XT the XT does a
better job for frame time pacing here as
for the 4060 CTI 8 GB that landed at 73
FPS average a lead over the 7600 XT of
about 18% the Intel a770 is at 67 FPS
average result also leads the 7600 XT
here at 1440p the RX 7600 XT is 111 FPS
average result leads the 7600 103 FPS
average by
8.3% so F1 seems to just scale better
between these two the a750 is down
alongside the 7600 with the a770 up with
the 7 600 XT nvidia's RTX 460 is between
the two RX 7600 cards creating options
basically every couple of FPS in this
area the total range encompassing all of
these models is relatively narrow so
it'll ultimately come down to other
features or to just price at time of
purchase at 1080p the RX 7600 XT leads
the 7600 by 3.3% with the 46d about tied
with the 7600 the a750 runs slower than
the 7600 here down at 13 4 FPS average
but with acceptable lows it's similar to
the 2070 super if you look at its
positioning but AMD 7600 XT scaling has
reduced as we've dropped the resolution
with this game which makes sense given
that most of the Improvement is
theoretically in the memory in Rainbow
Six Siege at 4K the RX 7600 XT ran at 82
FPS average leading the 7600 by
1.2% great that's at 4K so not expecting
a lot more as we continue the RTX 460 is
about tied with these results they are
basically all within run-to-run variance
you could effectively just random number
generate these if you gave it a normal
variable range for the test passes the
4060 TI leads more meaningfully although
it has its own issues with getting
embarrassed by the 3060 TI the a750
falls behind in this one but given the
new pricing it's not bad as a value
position at 4K 1440p the RX 7600 XT has
about a 1.6% lead over the RX 7600 now
if we worked at AMD we'd want that
number to sound more impressive so
here's how to do it in the 4K Tas the
7600 XT was 1.2% better than the 7600 in
this test it's 1.6% better so the
percent increase in percent increase is
actually
33% which sounds a lot better than a 0.4
percentage Point difference and it's
still technically correct which is the
only kind of correct that matters for
marketing the RTX 460 is just behind the
RX 7600 Baseline card and the a750 is
further down the stack than its
proportional ranking in some of the
other games Final Fantasy 14 is up now
at 4K the RX 7600 XT ran at 47 FPS
average leading the original 7600 by all
of
1.7% the a750 actually leads both of
these including in lows with a 48.8 FPS
average the 4 460 is ahead of that at 53
for 4K and that establishes a 133% lead
or so for the 4060 over the 7600 XT 4060
TI 63.6 FPS average result produces a
19.5% gap over the 4060 Baseline card as
for older cards the RTX 2070 is similar
in performance to the modern 7600 7600
XT leads the 6600 XT by about 6% so not
particularly exciting and that gives way
to 1440p the RX 7600 XT leads the
Baseline 7600 by 3% with the 6600 XT
about tied with the original 7600 even
if these are linked primarily by name
that's just a disappointing Swain the
original launch MSRP of the 66 XT was
380 bucks but we're going on 3 years
since its launch and not much has
changed GTA 5 at 4K at least posts more
of a change but still not enough to
justify the price the 7600 XT gains 8%
over the original 7600 here moving from
54 FPS average to 58 that puts the 76 XT
between the 460s 63 FPS average and the
360 xt's 57 FPS average Intel's a750
doesn't do that well here down at 31 FPS
average if anything this test helps to
show that Intel's GPU performance still
isn't predictable in the same way Nvidia
and AMD options might be generally
speaking we can pretty accurately
predict for example that a 7600 and a
4060 will be relatively close to each
other uh but the a750 still bounces
around based on on the game time for Ray
tracing testing we'll start with our
freshly Reed cyberpunk with a mix of RT
Ultra and RT medium leading with rt
medium at 1080p with medium RT the RX
7600 XT and RX 7600 are about equal to
an end user without upscaling upscaling
mostly proportionately scales and is
calculable so you can factor that in if
you'd like but the difference here for
Baseline is about 11% for these results
there's no heavy constraint on vram here
at least not anything exceeding what the
cards are already capable of as for the
RTX 460 its lead is massive here as
discussed in the summary chart we also
saw that with the 700 XT tying the 470
here and it gets worse as RT load
increases with ultra you could make this
work on the 7600 cards with upscaling
and settings tuned down a little more
but for our purposes we care about the
difference between the devices and
Nvidia does hold the lead at 1440p and
with medium still the RX 7600 XT posts
an 18 FPS average result this is more of
an academic exercise because the 7600 is
actually struggling enough here that its
FPS becomes less reliable generally
spikier so we have less data to work
with and it's also starting to get
overloaded as a card additionally in
situations of percent scaling plus or
minus one FPS at this range can have a
bigger difference on what's calculated
so these tend to get exaggerated
regardless the XT is significantly
improved here memory is never so simple
though the RTX 4060 has less than the
new XT but its Baseline performance and
ability to process RT helps it keep a
lead at 1080p Ultra the RX 7600 XT and
RX 7600 post similar scaling to the
1440p medium results the 4060 leads the
7600 XT by 85% here again with this
higher RT load Nvidia is just scaling
better we saw similar massive leads for
the 4070 TI super over the 7800 XT now
for ding Light 2 with Ray tracing and at
1440p here the RX 7600 XT ran at 31.3
FPS average leading the 7600 by about
6.8% it's on the higher side but still
not a huge sway for the price the RTX
460 runs this one at 415 FPS average
leading the 7600 XT Now by 33% 4060 TI
has an advantage of 70% over the 7600 XT
not distant from the 7700 XT and these
7600 series cards have a particular
weakness in certain rage raising tests
and that's showing here at 1080p we're
seeing a 7.6% advantage in the 7600 XT
over the original 7600 the cards still
struggle though ultimately Landing below
the Intel a750 and the RTX 460 both of
which are the low 60s for frame rate AMD
is struggling to get up into the 50s
with its 7600 series cards here in
Resident Evil 4 with r tracing and at
1440p the RX 7600 Baseline performed at
65 FPS average establishing an
improvement of 2.8% for the RX 7600 XT
that puts the 46d up at 71 FPS average
or 7 % ahead of the 7600 XT and at 1080p
the 7600 XT leads the 7600 by 2.2% the
4060 is about 12% ahead of the XT in
this one and the Gap isn't as wide here
for an RT test as we've seen in some
others like cyber buk or Dying Light
finally in flat out 100% power
consumption and fully maxed which is
similar Behavior to what you'd see in a
completely taxing render workload we
have the 7600 XT at 200 Watts against
the original 7600 non XTS 163 Watts
that's where a lot of the the
performance uplift is coming from in
situations where we did see 10 or 12%
swings like in Starfield and F1 it's
derived from the added power budget more
often than it is from the memory change
alone the V bios allowed up to 232 Watts
when overclocking which had it roughly
aligned with the much less efficient
a750 Nvidia 460 holds an overall
efficiency Advantage here frankly and
simply put this card is not particularly
interesting and serves as a great
reminder for everyone that more memory
for cards of this class of performance
it's not going to fix the core challenge
that they face which is they're just not
powerful enough to really leverage it so
there's one instance where we saw a
breakout where it actually did matter
AMD provided some first-party numbers it
had collected it I think it said like
Doom with ultra nightmare or whatever
and anyway there's a couple scenarios
that are functionally one-offs but for
our perspective there is a limit to what
can be leveraged for that memory
capacity and the amount of times you are
likely to leverage it unless you're
buying for a very specific use case it
just seems not worth the extra $70 or
whatever it ends up being when this
thing launches the rest of the average
five to 7% uplift we saw comes from
power increase and clock increase we
really just can't recommend the 7600 XT
the
7600 at least somewhat interesting $270
is really the primary reason that it is
so as soon as you take away that price
and you increase it this much uh it it
does kind of eliminate most of the
reasoning for buying a 7600 class even
still again the 6700 XT is still kind of
Hing in there that's worth looking at uh
and this launch being flanked by super
cards that at least had the courtesy to
retain a price with the upgrade or in
the case of the 480 super drop it it
makes it even harder to accept this card
from AMD but its biggest challenge once
again as has been the challenge for AMD
this entire generation is AMD it's
fighting itself there was so much 6000
series stock left in the market after uh
the kind of crypto collapse with
ethereum mining dropping off and the co
demand dropping off that they've just
been contending with those price points
of relatively good cards especially at
the price that they're uh sitting at now
and so you 330 bucks for 6700 XT is
worth looking at the 6600 is still
interesting they
50s it's kind of it's not one we can
outright recommend it's still in that
sort of Enthusiast you have some
troubleshooting experience and patience
Camp of recommendations but uh
ultimately the 7600 XT is just
surrounded by much more interesting
options we think and it's not something
we can recommend so uh this this one's a
a pass for us at the price um maybe if
it comes down and it will then we'll
talk about it again but for now we' pass
simple as that
uh it is not the most offensive card
that's launched in the last two years
it's just also not worth buying so
that's it for this review thanks for
watching as always subscribe more go to
patreon.com Gamers Nexus to help out
directly or go to store. Gamers
nexus.net and grab one of these limited
edition disappointment PC 2023 shirts
where we are running low in stock but
the back of it's got a list the most
disappointing Hardware events of the
year as a way to commemorate it and
support our new expanded testing thanks
for watching we'll see you all next time